let's take some audience questions first
one from Tammy David you talk about
being independent media but I see people
saying you were just like CNN and also
that you are fake news you do have
advertisers can you explain how you are
different from corporate media in a way
that will end all the confusion okay so
say can you sing we're not even going to
dig into that right now fake news now it
just becomes code for news I don't agree
with positions I don't agree with let's
talk about how we are different than
corporate media we do have advertisers
and I'll explain to you sort of how the
entire thing works we're mostly funded
through the membership program by
viewers right that's that's most of our
revenue we also are YouTube partners so
ads play before our videos on YouTube we
have absolutely no control over which
adds play the content we produce is in
no way influenced by the ads that play
we just literally have no control over
what ads plane sometimes it leads to add
playing that don't really make any sense
given the ideology of the show and I
think people have noticed that yeah or
sometimes we'll take a position on the
show and you'll see an ad for like a
pharmaceutical company on oil company
the exact opposite exactly and then then
we get to the advertisers which is a
very good question we do have some
advertisers on the show sometimes you
will see me talking about one advertiser
or another because advertising is a
really small percentage of our revenue
and because of the way that these ads
come to us through ad agencies we have
no direct contact with these advertisers
there's basically a total wall in terms
of editorial so we might get an advert I
just to pick one advertiser here like we
might have an ad for blue apron or
something like that blue apron will buy
some ads on our podcast couple ads here
and there one a week to a week through
an ad agency they come to us and they
say they are buying on this day we have
the opportunity to either approve or
turn down the advertiser and I would not
accept advertisers whose product or
service we disagree with so we have like
a chemical company that is really not a
company that does very good things in
fact it's a company that we've done
interviews where we're criticizing the
actions of that company
and we just turn them down and this is a
very very different relationship that we
have with advertisers and what you see
on corporate media the other thing that
I want to mention as far as the entire
corporate independent media thing goes
is that we aren't paid by any of the
platforms that we exist on in the way
that stations are paid by cable company
so when you have a network like CNN on
comcast for example CNN is being paid by
comcast to appear in that package and
sometimes it's a group of channels
sometimes its individual channels that
are paid in that way we give the show
away to all of the platforms that were
on as a result of that we are never
influenced by what it is that those
platforms want us to do and every once
in a while we'll lose an affiliate
because someone called up and complained
and said they'd really don't like that
David Pakman is saying X Y or Z but we
don't make any money from being on those
platforms we give the show we actually
produce the show at our expense and put
it on those platforms so that's another
way in which we are not being influenced
by the finances of these other
organizations or entities and even if
there could be the idea or an appearance
of a conflict of interest I've noticed
you just turn the advertisers down again
supplement companies people promoting
homeopathy yeah my personal favorite
which is bonus buckets we can be just
like Jim Bakker yeah I can be selling
food storage Mormon food storage or Jim
Bakker bonus bucket yeah we actually had
pets referring to weary I constantly
talk about how I don't believe in sort
of the bogus pseudoscience supplement
homeopathy all that stuff because it's
not science fact I mean some supplements
you know are completely science back if
you're not dating or getting you know
you nutrition you got to get it
somewhere else no doubt about it and
whether we're talking about you know
vitamin D and Ewing dead or whatever the
case but we got this sort of like
healthy energy snack I won't even say
what it is because people might be able
to figure out what it is they said we
want to advertise with you they were
offering money they sent the samples i
looked at the product it made completely
non science-based claims about
Sergey boosts and brain function and
also the number one ingredient when you
looked at the ingredients with sugar how
on earth am I going to justify or feel
even remotely into the idea of
suggesting to my audience that they buy
that product given my pro-science non
pseudoscience perspective that I've been
espousing for years interesting now if
they didn't make all those claims about
how this particular candy or chocolate
bar whatever it was would boost your
energy would you still advertise for it
given the amount of sugar that it has no
I wouldn't anyway let me know why am I
going to advertise a candy like that in
that way I just I just don't see it I
mean we've done like shari's berries in
the past which is berries that are
covered in chocolate for example and you
know it's special treat it's for maybe
Valentine's Day or whatever in fact I
wonder if they're going to advertise
with Valentine's Day coming up or
something like that and I'm not
suggesting people eat this as the
breakfast lunch and dinner but yeah it
like for example soda I can advertise
soda on the David Pakman show I think so
does a disaster for people's health yeah
you're taking a stand and yeah I don't
think those bars they have tasted pretty
good is not worth being advertised and
not that you'd know no I didn't handle
them or anything and also by the way
sometimes paid member you can say well
David you're liable to you're you're
responsible to your paid members in the
same way that CNN is responsible to
advertisers we've asked the members who
have written in saying I'm going to
cancel my membership if you don't change
your view on X I will immediately write
back to them and say we don't change
views on issues because of the threat of
cancelled memberships the whole point of
membership is that you support the
structure of the show and not that
you're going to bend withhold money
because you might not agree with us on
every issue try that one and see how far
it gets you so yes Tammy those are some
of the ways in which were different from
corporate media